once upon the time years catch demons
please welcome Houston
what many people know this but you're
actually half Swedish your mother was
your daughter yeah
absolute yeah I mean I don't speak more
than bah I'll have a few little words
but yes my mother was Swedish and from
here blue how much time did you spend
here well I've got a picture of me one
at one you know in in the lakes in
Sweden northern Sweden we have that
picture we have it yes we we borrowed it
if it's okay this is you and your sister
yeah I've got other ones which I'm
exposed a little bit more than that but
anyway so I chose that and actually I
went to school in in year before when I
was 8 for about 6 months and that was an
extraordinary experience because
probably the first time I realized that
was going to be a star because everybody
was staring at me
I had these brown eyes you know but at
that time everybody had blue eyes and
and so I had to have my own little
playground and I could choose my friends
and your father was from Greece right
yes yes there are lights from from
Cyprus that's thank you yes and III
wonder it you sit here now as as Yusuf
but can you explain for us the
difference between cat and yourself
there isn't really I'm sort of trying to
explain to people that I'm not two
different persons but that you know life
is an evolution it's a journey and you
can have many names you know your first
name is Sun you know you may become a
father husband brother I mean you have
many many names and I chose Cat Stevens
at a time when I needed to be recognized
I needed to be known
I chose Youssef after a great deal of
journey and finding myself and and many
things that I've been dreaming about so
many things came true for
Mia's use of things that I was dreaming
about is his cat was there was there
it's a kind of defining moment was there
was there was this the moment in Malibu
where you almost drowned because there
is a story about you almost drowning and
I'm turning you to God is that right
that's right that's one of the incidents
and and there are many other lead ups to
that for instance I was on the road you
know at the age of 18 with Jimi Hendrix
you know and one year of that kind of
life and I crashed in hospital having a
weird disease TB I started to think
about this path that I was on and I
decided to aim a little bit higher than
this world and try to find out a little
bit about what was going to happen next
you know because we all die and there's
a big question if you don't ask that
question you may be losing out you know
in the end you may find out something
that you didn't know before so that was
one of the important points in my life
then of course well I started singing
songs after that about about my journey
and wrote to find out you know father
and son song about leaving home about
getting on that journey joining the
revolution and finally there was a point
where I've made it I've made it really
big but I hadn't found that place and I
was I was swimming in Malibu I wasn't a
bad swimmer you know but it was a very
strong current and that day I just
realized I had no power to hold myself
up and at that point there was no help
to be seen I said God if you save me
I'll work for you and at that moment a
little wave not a big wave not tsunami a
small wave just came push me forward
and I was back on land Wow
what next and after that I got a gift of
the Quran Aslam was not on my list to be
honest my father was Greek you know so
Turks he'd forget it
so but here was this book and I had an
open mind it was given to me by my
brother he wasn't a Muslim but he just
you know said yeah it's another book so
I read it and at that point I everything
came together you know I I recognized so
many things in that book which were part
of everything I've learned you know even
as a Christian but why did you have to
leave music because of this why couldn't
you just continue as Cat Stevens being a
Muslim you had it well yeah a huge
career at that time yeah that's true but
again a lot of people don't know but my
father wasn't well this was 1978 and I
came back to look after him and my
mother then I married and then I
realized that I could get a life I could
get off this road that road you know
which is like the heavy road or the
mountainous road tours and in agents and
everything when you when you think about
Cat Stevens being Cat Stevens is is that
does it give you a positive feeling or a
negative I like the curls I wouldn't
mind getting the curls back
what kind of reactions did you get when
I mean when your fans when when people
around you heard about this it was it
was difficult very difficult was many of
my fans because you know they've been
following me and you know and now I was
going in a direction which probably was
going to be very difficult for them to
follow and for many people it became an
opportunity to say all the nasty things
they ever wanted to say about me because
they didn't like my music or whatever
but for many it's been an incredible the
fact that people have hung around so
long and waited for me to come back it's
it's great and when we're not doing
music being a Muslim you were still a
very well-known person and and you you
turned into some kind of spokesperson
for for Islam and it seemed like you it
was reluctantly so how did you
experience that well I learned a lot of
lessons in that role which was again as
you say thrust upon me because hey here
is a famous guy famous Muslim let's ask
him you know and I was like hang on um
what I think it says you know blah and
all of a sudden I'm in hot water so as I
said you know you can you can argue we
refer with a philosopher but you can't
argue with a good song so I started to
write songs again what made you what
made you pick up the guitar you it was
actually my son who's got a love of
music who writes and and one day I was a
live in Dubai now and he bought the
guitar in the house I was like one
morning it was like me and the guitar
looking each other you know who's gonna
make the first move
come here and I got it and I just
started playing and I knew what I had to
do next because it was just so good so
strong and God had given me back my
music and how many years went before
this happened without a guitar Oh 20
years nothing yeah well a deletion for a
while can you see Islam with Western
eyes as well can you see that it it to
many Westerners Islam today is very
foreign a bit threatening